all right Ricky you're here at the Rich
Eisen salt Rich Eisen show I am Michael
Rapaport you're going to be
participating in the big three
professional basketball tournament this
summer your team is the ghost ballers
the captain is Mike Bibby you are the
co-captain I need to talk to you about
that I need to talk about where you are
as far as professional three-on-three
basketball game shape stamina but you
were with the Cleveland Cavaliers you
are a veteran mm-hmm and you were a
confident let's say the word confident
basketball player yes you you you you
you you are you had bravado oh yes this
young kid gets picked up on the team
he's on the cover this magazine cover
that magazine I saw LeBron on this
channel that channel he's dunking over
pimple-faced punks in Akron I was like I
yeah let me see some real action yeah at
what point did you realize that he was
totally legit and the real thing and did
you ever imagine that he wanted being
this great well I know he was the real
thing when he came in yes it was just a
matter of time to when he was going to
pick up and when he was going to
actually learn the game it's a
difference in being great and learning
the NBA game and him coming in at an
early age it I don't think he was ready
ready as fully his rookie year as he is
now so I was ready I was ready to go and
in the moment feeling confident right so
it was a good fit it came in and he did
his thing
but when when he first came into
training camp like he was NBA ready well
he was still young but was he confident
he was confident he was still a little
nervous still kind of filling his way
but you know he had a lot of height to
live up to and it was tough to live up
to that height but uh he played hard and
you know he had that green light so it's
kind of easy now you you you played an
era that when when the LeBron came in
there just Kobe there's a I I mean who
were the other like best players at that
time I was Kobe AI you know you have run
our test she had those guys down in
Indiana it was it was tough and it was
actually the air with no boys were
allowed
you know that's what the NBA used to
stand for no boys allowed so you know
Brian coming in at an early age kind of
you know he changed it up all right
we're in the mix of what I assume is
going to be a sweep I got the broom out
I am the wicked wicked witch it's really
when I brought this right into Quicken
Loans David Rick oh yeah I wasn't
playing games there okay the party's
over we're going to get the Cleveland
sports fans right back into their
comfort zone disappointment heartbreak
and and just tears to painful tears this
series did you imagine that that it
would want to be like like just sort of
a lopsided I predicted go and say would
win in six games
I wanted five but I didn't see this
coming nobody saw this car I didn't see
this at all
I thought they least were the one you
know maybe one and go to state maybe one
at home but they just didn't show up
and then last game they gave everything
they had they just they needed somebody
else to step up and go to state you know
with that Cady Edition kind of possible
what is your opinion of this whole super
team big three friends and family AAU
skinny jean efficacious and that delay
but but you know Brian is to blame I
hate it you know cuz yeah you need to
blame he goes running over there the
d-wade and join those teams so he kind
of started the fab of everybody running
to superstar teams and you know all-star
teams you know just to win a
championship so it's not from where I
come from it's not it's not acceptable
do you think that the NBA in the long
term and I'm talking about three four
five years will be in shambles because
it's because of the lopsided and the
competitiveness and also you're seeing
these kids they did the next generation
of no-name you know who's who guys that
are 14 15 16 they're watching and
idolizing Kevin Durant they're watching
and idolizing D way because D way is
responsible to LeBron gets all the blame
hey Chris Bosh is responsible - oh yeah
you know as much I like to point the
finger at LeBron those guys are
responsible for a - do you think that
you know like people are going to think
that's the only way to win and you have
to win a ring and everybody sees Charles
Barkley you know get made fun of because
he doesn't have a ring and Pat Ewing
there's a special Club for the quote
unquote
the great losers do you think this is
going to affect the NBA I mean how do
you think they could fix because now you
got Durant who came to a homegrown big
three and he went there and he went
through all the scrutiny and I'm glad
that LeBrons big three is getting bit in
the butt by a big four right because
because he started it he started it yeah
it's tough because you know now now
these generation kids all they see is
all they see is the winners and they see
three four players on one team and the
wins and it's just not the way the world
is they think it's so easy right I think
I can just join a team and be a winner
but it's difficult it is difficult on
James obviously he's under pressure
right now he talked to the media
yesterday if we could go to that you
guys over there and you know where he
was so my now he's kind of kind of being
like he exonerating himself from the big
three let's go to LeBrons a clip we will
have it in a second I'm new to this
I'm not true to this yes Pretty Ricky
will have it ending up I believe I
believe the fellows in our control room
live here and three two oh maybe not yet
Mike alright well listen you played with
so many first I'll ask you Dwyane Wade
when when when your grandkids ask you
when you're 90 dad
granddad what was the Wayne Wade like as
a teammate as a player well what do you
say it was great he was a flash you know
he was everywhere he's all over floors
everywhere stealing the ball these guys
changed the game at any time when he's
healthy
so it was great just playing with those
guys Kevin Garnett I might question
about Kevin Garnett won one of the
greatest power forwards ever one of the
greatest players ever the big ticket uh
never never never quiet what was he
talking he's talking to himself I talked
to his teammates
did he ever yeah you know though he
could could that commercial where he had
like four different personalities ah
that's him so he's talking to himself
he's talking to his other character
she's talking to stuff to get his hype
he's just everywhere he's hyping himself
up but that guys gave me it gave me a
respect of what a work ethic is what why
what did he do what did you see in him I
mean he and that we don't see he showed
the work ethic on the court off the
court
stretching talking watching film he's
just a very intense
and he lets you know you know every play
every second of how intense and how
passionate you need to be one of my
favorite players of all time I mean you
had some career man
Paul Pierce he squirt he you know he
just retired but like he never lost the
step because I don't think he ever had
like hello man game at 21 he was moving
slow at 21 so it's hard when you know
moving slow going fast moving slow going
fast cagey right here so Paul Paul's a
great guy I am
he's awesome where you at in your shape
have you been working out for the big
because I'm gonna tell you right now
I've seen some of the practice games
yeah and I'm telling you right now you
need to be ready because the pace of the
games was the 14 second shot classes
have you been working out all I'm ready
you ready to go yeah I still got
something which one changes in your mind
from a half-court game twelve quarter I
change like you said the 14 second shot
clock you know the three on three
there's not another guy to go help up
you know clearing the ball back and
forth and of course playing half court
it's a different technique so you got to
go in there and pick up on that
technique and it's going to be a
fast-paced game what uh what are you
expected from your team the ghost
ballers Mike Bibby who I played I saw
him play in another tournament he's
coming in Mike baby he's been on the 50
cent diet he's like you jack alright
yeah I don't really try to like you know
they call him like debo you got Moe
Evans Marcus banks but your team I mean
what are you what are you expecting from
this torn because I I'm just telling you
right now I hope you're expecting the
competitiveness because guys are playing
ball guys are getting ready guys are
getting in shape and I've seen
everywhere guys are getting ready so
we're going to be fast we'll be quick
and you know you got to be fast quick
and smart at the same time be able to
play three on three so it's gonna be fun
okay
the Russell Westbrook MVP triple-double
campaign which seems like so long ago oh
yeah
I mean like did the regular season ended
like almost two months ago now some ago
and and and he averaged the
triple-double was triple double triple
double you had this sort of iconic sort
of faux pas
whatever where you were going for a
triple-double and and you know you you
think got Twitter didn't exist no I
would have been all over they got it
snapchat everything common all over how
hard is it to get a triple-double in the
NBA and how impressive is what Russell
Westbrook did this season um it's
amazing you know for someone like myself
that was chasing triple doubles you know
for a game or two this guy came off and
did it for a whole season so hand down
you know he had my vote for MVP you know
not just because he has a triple-double
like I try to give but just because he
goes out he was by itself he set the
tone every night and he did some
everything he could to make the team win
who was the most impressive person that
you had to guard who was the player
during your career were you were like yo
I need to get a little rest
I need to get high why oh man he didn't
stop I mean guys a - he's a point guard
at playing a to guard and I mean just
from floaters the jumpers the dunks to
anything crossing over he had your
skates he all night all night and what
about a Kobe Kobe stuff you know Kobe
I'ma be like hope he's planning it
trying and what does that mean it's a
little easier to guard Kobe it's because
I'm not easy I got you I got you the
system you're not running on Ricky Ricky
Davis just said it's easy to guard Kobe
Bryant when I got a contact we put it on
Twitter oh hey I was impressive I all
right that's good we're making news I
need to find a way to make news and the
Moses show not not easy at all not easy
at all book
hey I never stopped moving and Kobe was
in that spot and you had to stop him in
that spot so it was tough yeah Ricky let
me ask you this here's our poll question
today what would be more surprising to
you the Warriors complete the sweep
tonight going 16 and OH in the playoffs
or a LeBron James led team gets swept in
the finals who I say I say - 18 18 wins
18 wins everything 16 yeah 18 wins and
playoffs is impressive especially going
to the finals you know just kind of
proves why they got Kady you know 16
wins just something you don't hear of
you know to go undefeated in the
playoffs and it's just stuff yeah right
now 40% agree with you 60% more shock
that LeBron getting swept that's that's
where we're at in the polls all right
all right well I'm in the minority but I
mean I think though the the whole thing
is I mean there's been all this talk
this season about the playoffs being you
know weak and water down and these what
is your take on that it was a little
water down you know but you got the
teams that's they're stacked so of
course these stack teams are going to
sweep through these other good teams
that's just playing hard off you know
playing good as team ball but you know
tune balls just out the door when you
got talent you know when you got
all-stars five or ten all-stars on one
tonight it's just impossible it's
impossible
all right do we got the clincher made me
look bad one flaw I know you're not
going to make me look bad again I'm here
with Ricky Davis
all the work shipshape with a big three
at you wants because you said so much to
me the command man and I'm like I'm just
gonna put on you it wasn't me I walked
in with this guy who's from filling away
from from central um from Penn State
thank your from Penn State State College
okay okay so you got the clip here
LeBron James but here's what we're gonna
do we're going to catch a 60-second
break we're going to come back with more
with Ricky Davis you'll say we'll play
with LeBron James sound and then we'll
hear what your guys hotcakes are like
LeBron are like Kobe's easy to guard I'm
sure Ricky laughing oh yeah that's what
he said Kobe Bryant that was a day to
the Parker you all right stay tuned this
is the Rich Eisen show i am michael
rapaport filling in stay tuned with
Ricky Ricky Davis and we're gonna hear
what LeBron James has to say about the
big three when it's biting him in the
butt
that is the sounds of Cleveland's own
the late great Bobby Womack Ricky Davis
they finally have the cliff lined up
LeBron James cooked I was on yes yes no
way near old days try to throw me under
the bus I thought you was in a box yeah
let's look here LeBron had to say about
the big three all of a sudden it's a
problem yes if you have the opportunity
to do that it will fare that the Cowboys
added Deion Sanders I mean listen I mean
happens in sports you know you could
have an opportunity to sign one of the
best players and you can do it go ahead
and do it why not
if I become owner i'ma try to sign
everybody
what did you take on this I mean I'm
exaggerating but you know I feel like
he's like he's go just give it up he's
given up yeah
he's given up an excuse it's an excuse
yeah have you ever seen a coach tyloo
after game one when they got blown out I
never seen a coach in any sport say
they're the best I've ever seen that
whole series here manager is coming come
on don't give him that upper hand
already and I know you played a name in
the late 90s Tyler but you know what
your suit looks like it's from the late
90s eyes of Joe so long I'm not saying
you gotta wear skin tight legs a really
long you know it looks like he ain't got
a dress you know I mean I I'm gonna see
that to be crazy fitted like nuts but
like get a chute to look you look nice
on watch not sleeping bag ha ha ha ha I
don't know man I honestly think that
this big 3 big for this whole you know
we're going to gang up on each other
thing I really think it's going to
discombobulate
yeah we're right now setting the
precedent for these young kids it has to
that you know you shouldn't you have to
join it three four guys that win a
championship you know should be one or
two guys good nucleus and well San
Antonio is kind of proving people wrong
on that so I love San Antonio about the
system and playing hard and effective so
that's what it's all about
um Ricky Davis Rich Eisen show Michael
Rapaport filling in twelve seasons in
the NBA playing in the big three
professional basketball tournament
did you ever see
that three-on-three would be part of the
Olympics and I think that the big three
that we're participating in this summer
is going to really be the you know sort
of introduced the world to it but now
they just announce today that the three
on three basketball inland rivers United
States is going to they should even we
should even be allowed to hide now that
should be cheating right we're going to
kill that I think it's great I think
it's fun especially now that we're doing
that big three
you know things so it's going to be
great we're going to have the experience
especially with that four-point play NBA
didn't want to do it for so long so I
think it would be a great experience for
that four-point play now Gary Payton is
one of the coaches of a team in the big
three now I consider myself a guy who
likes to talk and you said Kevin Garnett
Gary Payne's on another planet he's on
the woman who talks more Gary Payton or
Kevin Garnett like who would shut up
first me would submit neither one like a
day was he's napping one we doesn't stop
you're gonna talk he's got a problem I
did had any finish a cool way to sleep
haha I don't know he just doesn't stop
he does stuff alright Ricky you played
in Cleveland you were there when it all
started with LeBron three down tonight
Game four what's your prediction how's
this game than unfold tonight are they
going to resist it all Cleveland I don't
know Golden State's on all-time high
they're rolling you know Cleveland got
to step up are you gonna get that broom
out yeah we get to sweep in they got to
step up no excuses
I think the party's over he's got a step
and I suggest everybody takes a room on
Cleveland Stephanie Ricky would you
rather lose 400 or four three like would
you rather lose the heartbreak in Game
seven the or Jeff no it's over
early never gets wet never gets will
never get swept that means you weren't
supposed to be there to first place real
Kings don't get swept yeah I read
Shakespeare yeah and I know all the
Shakespeare that I read it never said
anything about and then the King got
sweat work never but it's a disrobing
party yeah you know Kanye and jay-z had
watch
thrown this is called watch the dethrone
me role and they throw the Dean's Roman
will be televised that night 6 p.m.
Pacific Coast time 9 p.m. Eastern the
actual dethronement of a king this week
this is the Rich Eisen show Ricky Davis
I appreciate you coming on and joining
me hug I can't wait to see you do your
thing this summer in the big 3 games
start the 25th they will air the 26th of
June of Fox Sports 1 and I'm going to be
the Howard Cosell of the big 3 it's
going to be fun listen what else we got
law you can call it'll break here we're
gonna catch a break here Brockman's got
a little fun numbers game as it pertains
to the NBA Finals
we're in hey little Michael Rapaport
final segment out the door the command
center has some questions for you yeah
and then we're off to our weekend can't
wait are you going to be what are you
gonna be doing tonight by air bursary is
Tuesday so I know you're talking about
me it'd be like I'm watching a game but
I mean chicken slide that Book of Mormon
when you're going to you could watch a
Dean throw me to an actual live TV it's
never happened before
anniversaries through Tuesday the Book
of Mormon oh they got comfortable seats
how will we get backward I'm going to
talk to you about go easy on me yeah
that's good
your wife doesn't want to watch the game
she hates sports alright why the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you like some of that get
some more of that on the Rich Eisen show
lap follow all the information you see
right here on the Rich Eisen show